Speaker 1: This story is one I didn't pay
much attention to at the beginning because
as I heard about it, I thought, this has to
be a joke.
There's no way Republicans are this stupid.
But unfortunately, any time your instinct
is Republicans couldn't possibly be the stupid,
take a step back and investigate because Republicans
really could be the stupid.
Republicans are blaming Joe Biden's administration
for a shortage of some sources at the chicken
chain Chick fil A, often affiliated with homophobic
right wing ideology.
I thought it was a joke, but it's real.
Chick fil A announced that it was going to
limit how much sauce it would give customers
because of an industry wide supply chain issue.
So customers were only get one cup of sauce
per item.
Now, I've never been to a Chick fil A, but
a cup of sauce seems like a lot.
I've never needed a cup of mayonnaise for
a meal.
I've never needed a cup of ketchup or a cup
of mustard for any meal I've ever had.
Let's put that aside for a second.
Radical Trumpy and Congresswoman Lauren Bobert
tweeted in response to the sausage shortage,
quote, Is there no limit to how awful Biden's
America can get?
Ted Cruz tweeted, Joe Biden is destroying
America about the sausage shortage.
Oklahoma Republican Governor Kevin's TYT,
his reelection campaign now claims that, quote,
Joe Biden's radical liberal policies are to
blame for the sauce shortage.
At Chick fil A, his campaign published a whole
thing saying Chick fil A, a gas source, Chick
fil A sauce shortage, gas shortage.
You want to know why?
Because of Joe Biden's radical liberal policies.
Now, of course, gas stations had the shortage
because of what happened to a pipeline, not
because of Joe Biden.
Gas prices are up and they have been during
the end of Trump's term because of increased
demand as we come out of the pandemic.
And now supposedly Chick fil A has a sauce
shortage also because of Joe Biden.
And it seems like a joke, but it is really
not.
Now, Kevin's tit also said groceries are costing
more.
That's true.
But that started before Biden and it doesn't
have anything to do with Joe Biden.
Now, I tried in order to do this story justice
to find out exactly how they believe Biden
caused a sausage shortage.
I couldn't find it.
My guess is it's something about Biden didn't
fix something related to supply chains or
Biden didn't open fast enough.
Something which would have fixed supply chains,
I don't know, doesn't make much sense.
But my guess is that it would be something
like that, that entire thanks Obama thing
from the Obama era where people would pretend
to blame Obama for the silliest thing.
I stuck my toe, my toe.
I got a paper cut.
Thanks, Obama.
Republicans today are making it a reality
with Joe Biden and Chick fil A. Now, someone
please explain to me, why do you need so many
sources at Chick fil A?
Is the food not good?
And you need to mask it with endless cups
of sauce.
You just need massive dumps of moldy.
Sources, I've never been to a Chick fil A,
I don't understand why the source controversy
is such a controversy, but maybe someone can
explain it to me.
Remember that Monday, Memorial Day.
We're getting very close now, my friends.
Monday, Memorial Day, we're doing a one day
membership special.
This is such an outrageous discount off of
membership that I can't even tell you what
it is now.
But if you want to be notified on Memorial
Day, it's very easy.
You go to David Pakman Dotcom, you sign up
for my newsletter, and on Monday, Memorial
Day, you will get a perfect email telling
you exactly how to take advantage of this
great discount.
We have a great program for you today.
Looking forward to hearing from some of you
answering some of your questions and much
more coming up.
Stay with us.
Find me on Twitter
at David Pakman